we got Chelsea we would love you to be
on our show oh it's on the air now we're
actually going into our second season
yeah weird I haven't heard anything
about it at all well that is the scene
from The Comedy Series barely famous
which pokes fun at celebrity reality
shows now this is a world that the two
stars know pretty well sisters Aaron and
Sara Foster have lived their entire
lives swimming inside the celebrity
fishbowl I got to be honest I'm just now
a full-fledged celebrity their dad is
David Foster the Grammy award-winning
composer and X of Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills star Yolanda Hadid so yes
that makes them stepsisters to Gigi and
Bella you guys pulled out all the stops
and this is all I know you're famous
because there are so many a-list friends
in the season there are comfortable
around us knowing that they will always
be more famous than us I love the show
thank you yeah put my third or fourth
favorite reality show stars like Chris
Martin Jessica Alba Chelsea Handler and
Kate Hudson are among they're really
famous friends dropping by this season
but don't call them a [ __ ] don't really
don't want to have like it you can't sit
with us mentality our friend group is
always evolving and it's filled with
women who work their asses off and don't
be surprised to see bestie Kate Hudson
promoting the sisters on snapchat or
even sharing dating woes took my senator
guys you've actually hooked up with the
real thing come on come on
05 or something seventy-five percent
what can we set her up with like let's
get her look like I don't get her a man
don't you think she's a huge catch he
does not need us to set her up actually
I don't like hang out with her when I'm
single because I don't want to compete
with her for guys fun fun fun now look
these girls even got dr. Phil to make a
cameo in this series and you can watch
season two starting wednesday on vh